-You guys, this weekend
was St. Patrick's Day,
and, of course, there was
a big parade here in New York,
and a lot of men
were wearing kilts.
[ Laughter ]
It made the manspreading on the
subway even worse than normal.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Although in Washington,
the White House celebrated
by dyeing the fountain
on the South Lawn green...
which backfired when
the President yelled...
[ Imitates Trump ]
"Mountain Dew!"
And dove right in.
Nom nom nom! Om nom nom nom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did you see -- did you see this?
[ Laughter ]
-He's really a fan
of Mountain Dew.
-"Do the Dew!"
[ Laughter ]
Did you see this,
a meteorologist in Oklahoma City
tried to do an Irish jig.
Did you see this?
For St. Patrick's Day?
When her co-anchor decided
to join in. Watch this.
[ Irish jig playing ]
Here she comes. Yep.
Hey -- how you doing --
[ Laughter ]
[ Thud ]
-That was a really good fall.
-Oh, oh, oh.
That's a good fall.
[ Laughs ]
-Wow!
-"Today's high is 45 and the low
is...my co-anchor. Hey, Steven!"
-"My back! My back!"
-"I can't feel my legs!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What was he --
I don't know what he was doing.
-Oh, my God! [ Laughs ]
-Let's get to some news here.
It just came out, you guys,
that Trump's Secretary of State,
Rex Tillerson, was on the toilet
when he found out Trump
fired him on Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
Then Trump said...
[ Imitates Trump ]
"Well, what a coincidence.
I was on the toilet when I
tweeted that.
So basically, we talked
to each other."
[ Applause ]
That's right. Tillerson was on
the toilet when he was fired,
which explains why Jeff Sessions
and Betsy DeVos haven't used
the bathroom in six months.
They're like,
"Unh-unh. No way, man."
[ Grunting ]
"Unh-unh, I'm not gonna --
hold it in, hold it in."
Oh, and the Russian presidential
election was this weekend.
And I saw that --
yeah, Putin won.
[ Laughter ]
To get people to vote, Russian
officials were offering prizes
like Apple watches.
Sounds fun until you open
the box with your Apple watch
and it's still attached
to a hand.
And you go, "oh, this is--"
[ Laughter ]
"Still works."
Still has a pulse.
-Yeah.
-That's interesting, yeah.
The big story still
is March Madness. Right now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The tournament has been crazy
so far.
The other night, a 16th seed
beat a number 1 seed
for the first time ever,
when UMBC beat Virginia.
-Ow!
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's pretty nuts.
Until last weekend,
everyone thought UMBC was
a bank. And you...oh.
[ Applause ]
Some more sports news, golfer
Rory McIlroy says there should
be a limit to how much alcohol
fans can buy at events,
because they're getting
too rowdy.
Also, he's tired of hearing
drunk people
try to say "Rory McIlroy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurring ] "Rory McIlroy."
Rory McIlroy."
[ Normal voice ]
Like Tom Brokaw, yeah.
[ Slurring ] "Rory McIlroy.
[ Laughter ]
Rory McIlroy -- Rory --
R-R-R-Rory McIlroy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Get this, guys.
Engineers have crafted
a futuristic jetpack
that lets you fly up
to 10,000 feet in the air.
[ Audience oohs ]
It even has a cool name.
It's called "You Try It First."
Yeah. Kind of an odd thing.
[ Applause ]
And finally, I read about a man
in Ohio who just ended
his streak of eating Chipotle
for 500 straight days.
[ Audience ohs ]
When asked why he decided
to stop, his family said,
"oh, he died."
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!